california nevada arizona colorado and
utah the u.s simply wouldn't be the same
without them
hollywood silicon valley las vegas the
grand canyon these are all
quintessential symbols that make america
america but much like the empires before
america this land wasn't always a part
of the great american empire no no no
all these states and more used to belong
to america's southern neighbor mexico
but through a series of encroachments
wars negotiations and clever treaties
this vast area of land was strictly
mexicans and made a part of the us and
as a result america got immensely
wealthy from it while mexico they
suffered pretty terribly
the story of mexico losing its land to
the us is sadly the story of every major
power that has ruled this planet since
the beginning of civilization it's the
story of the french the dutch the
spanish the chinese the japanese and
much more when they were all at their
heights the ruling power encroaches on
the lesser powers and the victor writes
the history books i personally still
love america it's given me everything
that i have but like the other darker
american stories we've covered on this
channel this is a story that deserves to
be told
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime on my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
all you have to do is follow me on
instagram at jake tran and you're
automatically entered a few of you have
won already watch out for fake accounts
i will never message you asking for
money or to invest and this is how the
us stole mexico
it is no secret that stem jobs are among
the highest paid positions in the world
information security analysts make more
than 98 000 a year web developers bring
in over 108 thousand dollars per year
and network architects make over 120 000
a year the problem is learning the math
and science required for these positions
is really boring and intimidating but
thankfully that is where brilliant comes
in brilliant is a learning platform that
helps you learn valuable stem skills
that can make you a lot of money and you
do this through captivating interactive
courses that are way funnier than the
traditional way of learning the stuff a
great place to start is their computer
science learning path that goes over
things like computer science
fundamentals and algorithm fundamentals
if that doesn't sound like your thing
well don't worry because there are a ton
of other courses like apply probability
and math for quantitative finance
brilliant has helped over 11 million
people truly understand essential stem
concepts through hands-on courses and
interactive problem solving instead of
just memorizing stuff like they have you
do in school so if you're ready to start
building these profitable skills go to
brilliant.org jtram with the link below
and sign up for free the first 200
people that sign up with my link will
get twenty percent off brilliant annual
premium subscription that's
brilliant.org jake tran for 20 off now
thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
in 1821 mexico gained independence from
spain after fighting against them for
more than 300 years but becoming a
successful independent country turned
out to be a whole lot more complicated
than anyone in mexico expected right off
the bat
no one could decide who should lead the
country or how which led to a whole lot
of fighting and a very unstable
government and then to make matters
worse spain came right back and tried to
take over mexico again and when spain
didn't succeed france also tried their
luck it seemed like mexico just couldn't
catch a break no matter how hard they
tried right until seemingly out of
nowhere america mexico's big bad
neighbor to the north stepped in and
laid down the rules
you see america had originally been
settled by europeans looking to escape
their oppressive governments and they
didn't exactly like the idea of some
european country like spain or france
taking over the north american continent
they really didn't want to have worked
so hard to get away from europe's rules
just to be surrounded by their colonies
again it would be like living in europe
all over again so in 1823 president
james monroe decided to make a statement
and put them in their place
he told europe that now that america was
a rich and powerful nation they wouldn't
get involved in europe's affairs as long
as europe would agree not to create any
new colonies in the western hemisphere
or try to interfere with any of their
politics
it was a classic you stay out of my
business and i'll stay out of yours
arrangement and it became known as the
monroe doctrine
americans were pretty proud of the
monroe doctrine and what it stood for it
meant they had finally made it onto the
global stage america could tell europe
what to do and they would just have to
listen
but it also put america in a tricky
position you see just like their
european ancestors americans really
liked the idea of conquering all of
north and maybe even south america but
now with the monroe doctrine basically
saying hands off the west they would
look like pretty big hypocrites if they
tried taking anyone else's land luckily
in 1845 james polk became president of
america and he had some pretty clever
ideas on how to get around the pesky
monroe doctrine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
president james polk was a firm believer
in manifest destiny the idea that white
americans were destined to take control
of all of north america and the only
thing standing in their way was the
monroe doctrine if they wanted to
conquer north america while still
looking like they respect the doctrine
they would have to do it in a way that
looked nothing like what europe used to
do they couldn't just invade kill a
bunch of people and claim the land as
their own they would have to use subtler
tactics that looked less like conquering
and a little more like making a friendly
arrangement so in 1845 president polk
sent a representative to mexico to ask
if america could buy alta california the
ex-mexican state we know as california
today alta california was believed to be
rich in gold and if president poke could
get his hands on some of it america
would have all the money it needed to
buy up as much of its neighbor's land as
possible so president polk offered the
new mexican government 30 million
dollars for the state or around 1.2
billion in today's money
mexico was furious
they couldn't believe america had the
audacity to offer to buy a massive chunk
of their land for just 30 million
dollars did they really think they were
that hard up they were so angry the
mexican government even refused to meet
with president polk's representative and
he was sent packing back to washington
so polk's first plan had failed but
luckily he had a few more tricks up his
sleeve
[Music]
in the 1820s the newly independent
mexico quickly realized it was going to
need a lot of help turning its economy
around and making a success of itself
and one of the ways it tried to do it
was by inviting americans to farm on
mexican land as the years went by more
and more american families moved to the
mexican state of tejas and set up farms
and towns wherever they went by 1829 the
americans in tejas actually outnumbered
the native mexicans and that's where the
trouble started
you see all the americans in tejas
didn't really like the idea of living
under a mexican government mexico had
also just abolished slavery which was
really bad news for all the american
farmers who used slaves to work their
land so the americans wanted out they
wanted to join america where slavery was
still totally legal and no one would
stand in the way of them and their
farming profits but leaving mexico
wasn't going to be as easy as just
switching sides because they felt like
it they would have to be smart about it
so they went to war with more money and
more guns than the poorly trained and
equipped mexicans it was a piece of cake
and in 1836 tejas became the independent
republic of texas a country with its own
government and its own rules
the only problem with all of this was
mexico knew most texans wanted to become
part of america and if they did mexico
would never have the chance to take back
their land ever again
so mexico made it clear annexing texas
or trying to make it an official part of
america would be an act of war and that
was all president polk needed to start
the war that would cost mexico half of
its land
[Music]
for almost 10 years texans tried to get
america to take them in as a member
state at first most of the more liberal
states disagreed they didn't want
another conservative pro-slavery state
to join the union and shift the balance
of power between the north and south
right until president tolk took power he
didn't care if texas was pro-slavery or
not all he cared about was expanding
america's borders so in 1845 under
polk's encouragement congress finally
voted to offer to annex the republic
basically america was offering to
officially make texas a state of america
in preparation for what he knew was
coming
president polk ordered american troops
to camp along the american texan border
to stop mexico from interfering once
texas accepted their offer and in
december 1845 texas officially became
america's 28th state
american troops entered their new
territory and as expected mexico
prepared itself for war on president
polk's orders american soldiers moved
closer and closer to texas's border with
mexico they made it look like america
was about to invade mexico to keep the
upper hand mexican troops attacked first
killing 11 american soldiers little did
they know that by doing so they had just
played right into president polk's hands
[Music]
the monroe doctrine may have made it
unacceptable to invade a country in the
western hemisphere but it didn't say
anything about going to war to protect
american citizens as soon as mexico
attacked the american troops in texas
president polk announced that mexico had
quote shed american blood on american
soil end quote and that was grounds to
go to war so congress did what polk had
wanted all along and declared war on
mexico the game was on
let's face it compared to america's
money guns and troops the mexicans were
not in a great position to fight back
right from the start it was clear who
the winner was gonna be and after
throwing the first punch mexico couldn't
exactly justify asking anyone for help
to protect themselves they had started
the war and now they would have to see
it through themselves in just a little
over a year america nearly destroyed the
entire country and took over every
single one of the mexican states along
america's border by late 1847 american
troops had gone so far as to capture
mexico city the country's capital
down on their luck and suffering massive
losses of life and money the mexican
government knew if it didn't end the war
soon there would be nothing left of
their country
so they took a seat at the negotiating
table and accepted the fact that the
negotiations were not going to end on a
high note
[Music]
almost completely occupied by american
soldiers and volunteer fighters mexico
didn't have a lot of bargaining power
when it came to discussing a peace
treaty the government fought tooth and
nail to keep america from taking its
land but as talks carried on and more
american soldiers flooded into mexico
they realized they were fighting a
losing battle
enter the treaty of guadalupe hidalgo
the agreement that brought a two-year
war to an end here's what the treaty
said
for winning the war america would be
able to keep the mexican states in which
they had the most troops that meant
california nevada utah new mexico
arizona
colorado and parts of oklahoma kansas
and wyoming all of these states were
once part of mexico but were awarded to
america after winning the
mexican-american war
mexico was also forced to relinquish any
claims it had on texas allowing it to
fully integrate into the united states
in the end more than 55 percent of
mexico's land was handed over to america
as part of the treaty and in exchange
america agreed to stop invading mexico
and pay the mexican government 15
million dollars for the damages caused
and losses incurred during the war
that's around half a billion today
they also agreed to forgive three
million dollars of debt mexican citizens
owed to americans and that was it
president polk had gotten what he wanted
america had taken over more than half of
mexico's land and it had cost them less
than the 30 million dollars they had
offered to pay for california just three
years earlier plus no one could say they
violated the monroe doctrine because
technically mexico was responsible for
starting the war
it was one of america's biggest
strategic political successes yet but it
was about to become even more profitable
than president polk or anyone in the
american government could ever have
imagined
[Music]
president polk had always suspected
there was gold to be mined in california
it was one of the reasons he was willing
to offer mexico 1.5 billion dollars in
today's money to buy it and make it part
of america
and he wasn't wrong
just days before the mexican government
signed the treaty of guadalupe hidalgo
and handed over ownership of california
to america gold was discovered in the
state
but by then it was too late
the deal between mexico and america was
as good as signed
in the next seven years which became
known as the california gold rush more
than 750 000 pounds of gold was
extracted worth about 500 million
dollars then and around 17 billion
dollars today
in just the first two years of the gold
rush more gold was extracted in
california than america had paid for
half of mexico's land
if mexico hadn't gone to war and lost
california there's a chance it would
have been far more powerful developed
and a whole lot richer than it is today
and that wasn't even the end of the
harsh consequences mexico had to face
for daring to stand up against the only
global superpower
[Music]
in 1922 all those states that america
had bought from mexico decided they
needed the water in the colorado river a
whole lot more than mexico needed it
after all they had big developed cities
paid for with money from the gold rush
obviously they deserved to take the
biggest share of the water so they
divided it up damned it and rerouted it
across america's southern states leaving
mexico with nothing but a few sad drops
running in from across the border
and sure it must have been disappointing
to discover the new water agreement
everyone signed offered the entire
country of mexico less than half the
water allotment they gave california but
what made it even worse was the fine
print the part of the agreement where
mexico was chosen as one of the first
parties to lose its water rights in case
of a drought right now america's south
is experiencing one of its worst
droughts in history water levels in dams
are falling rain is scarce and everyone
is desperately trying to figure out what
to do once the water runs out but while
mexico has already cut its water usage
by more than five percent in the hopes
of keeping the dams full american
farmers are being forced to waste water
on crops they don't really need just so
they don't lose access to their water
entirely known as use it or lose it laws
there are rules in place so that if a
farmer doesn't use a specific amount of
water every month or year the overall
amount of water they're allowed to use
can be massively cut
leaving them without enough supply to
keep their farms going so while mexicans
are experiencing water shutoffs and
shortages as the government tries to
save the water in america's dams
american farmers are planting crops they
don't need and irrigating empty fields
wasting millions of gallons of water
just to keep up with some law the
government made decades ago
[Music]
america has a track record of using
questionable tactics to get what it
wants and starting an unnecessary war
with mexico isn't even the worst of it
for nearly two centuries the american
government has carried out dozens of
coups and secret operations around the
world that make what it did to mexico
look like a walk in the park we're
talking murder enhanced interrogation
and human rights violations and the
cia's black site program is probably one
of the best examples of how dark these
secret operations could get
for nearly a decade countless arabic men
and women of which many were innocent
were accused of being terrorists they
were arrested or kidnapped rounded up in
secret prisons around the world and
subjected to some of the harshest most
violent enhanced interrogations the cia
could dream up while america was
accusing countries like syria and iraq
of human rights violations its soldiers
and intelligence officers were doing
nearly the exact same thing to their
prisoners without even charging them
with a crime
and the lengths these cia officers went
to in their war against terror get
darker than anything we've ever
published before
but let's be real
a video on the cia's black sites and how
enhanced interrogation likely still
happens today would probably set off a
million red flags and get instantly
demonetized by youtube which is why
we've made it a full-length private
documentary that's only available to
members of this channel all you have to
do to get access to this documentary
right now as well as the other
feature-length videos we've already
published on monsanto the company that
owns the world's food supply mk ultra
the cia's mind control program efforty
jepsteen and the roots of terror in the
middle east is to click that join button
below people pay tens of thousands of
dollars every year to universities only
to leave not knowing anything about how
the world really works
but by becoming a member you get all
this priceless information for just five
dollars a month and we promise you it's
way more entertaining than university
lectures plus there's also a refund
policy unlike most youtube memberships
so if you join and you don't think it's
worth it email us within your first
month of joining and we will personally
refund you for your first month after
your first month there is no refund so
scroll down and click that join button
below right now
what's up guys hope you guys enjoyed the
video and if you're new here my name is
jake and this is one of the biggest
channels on youtube for documentaries on
money power war and crime be sure to
click that subscribe button for more
remember you can always dislike and
unsubscribe whenever you want so you
have nothing to lose and everything the
game but yeah i'll keep this one short
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you